عقد في الرياض الاجتماع الوزاري التشاوري
بشان الحرب الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه
بمشاركه وزراء خارجيه قطر ومصر والاردن
والامارات وال السعوديه اضافه الى امين
السر اللجنه التنفيذيه لمنظمه التحرير
الفلسطينيه اكد الاجتماع على ضروره انهاء
الحرب على غزه والتوصل لوقف فوري وتام
لاطلاق النار وضروره رفع كل القيود التي
تعرقل دخول المساعدات الانسانيه الى قطاع
غزه كما شدد على دعم الانرو وحث كل وحث كل
الداعمين لها على القيام بدورهم تجاه
اللاجئين واشار البيان الختامي للاجتماع
الى اهميه اتخاذ خطوات لا رجعه فيها
لتنفيذ حل الدولتين وشدد على الاعتراف
بدوله فلسطين على حدود عام
1967 وعاصمتها القدس الشرقيه كما اكد ان
قطاع غزه جزء لا يتجزا من الارض
الفلسطينيه المحتله واعلن رفض كل عمليات
التهجير القصري من قطاع
غزه معنا من الرياض مراسل الجزيره بدر
الربيعان بدر حدثنا عن اهم ما في هذا
الاجتماع
نعم عثمان اهم ما ورد في بيان هذا
الاجتماع الذي استضافته هنا وزاره
الخارجيه السعوديه واستمر لما يقرب حوالي
الساعتين هنا اولاها ضروره انهاء الحرب
على قطاع غزه والتوصل الى وقف فوري لاطلاق
النار والعمل ايضا على ضمان حمايه
المدنيين وفقا للقانون الانساني الدولي
اضافه الى رفع كافه القيود التي تعرقل
دخول المساعدات الانسانيه الى قطاع غزه
ايضا شدد وزراء الخارجيه الخمس بالاضافه
الى امين سر اللجنه التنفيذيه لمنظمه
التحرير الفلسطينيه حسين الشيخ على اهميه
اتخاذ خطوات جاده وفاعله ايضا لتنفيذ مسار
حل الدولتين والاعتراف بدوله فلسطين على
حدود 67 وعصمتها القدس الشرقيه ايضا
الجديد في هذا البيان عثمان هو تعبير
المجتمعون هنا عن دعمهم لوكاله غوث وتشغيل
اللاجئين الفلسطينيين الاونر هذا مجمل ما
تطرق له بيان الاجتماع التشاوري بخصوص ملف
الحرب الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه اليوم
ايضا وزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير فيصل
بن فرحان تلقى اتصالين احدها من وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني بلينكن اضافه
الى اتصال ايضا من وزير الخارجيه الفرنسي
بالتزامن مع اعمال هذا الاجتماع بحث
خلالها مستجدات الاوضاع في قطاع غزه وجهود
التعامل مع تداعياتها على المستوى
الانساني والامني وايضا على المستوى
السياسي حقيقه لا يوجد ما يمكن الحديث عنه
من ناحيه الراي السعودي سوى ما ذكره بيان
سعودي صدر اول من امس انه لن يكون هناك
علاقات دبلوماسيه مع اسرائيل ما لم يتم
الاعتراف بالدوله الفلسطينيه المستقله على
حدود 67 كما ذكر ايضا ونص احد بنود هذا
البيان الصادر اليوم من خلال هذا الاجتماع
ايضا ايقاف العدوان الاسرائيلي على قطاع
غزه وانسحاب كافه افراد قوات الاحتلال من
القطاع بلينكن كان قد زار الرياض خلال
الايام القليله الماضيه في اطار الجوله
الاقليميه الخامسه التي يقوم بها الى
المنطقه التقى خلالها ولي العهد السعودي
الامير محمد بن سلمان بحث معه ايضا ملف
حرب غزه التي دخلت شهرها الخامس وبطبيعه
الحال السعوديه مهتمه اكثر بشكل كبير لوقف
اطلاق النار بشكل فوري ودخول المساعدات
الى قطاع غزه والرفض بشكل قاطع ايضا تهجير
الفلسطينيين من اراضيهم حتى اللحظه يعني
لا يوجد الاتفاق الا ما تم البحثه اليوم
وايضا بثه من خلال هذا البيان على الاقل
في الحركه الدبلوماسيه القائم خصوصا ان
الحرب في غزه خلال الفتره الماضيه شاهد
توسع من خلال بعض الاشتباكات التي تجري في
الحدود اللبنانيه اضافه الى ملف التصعيد
الذي يجري في البحر الاحمر وايضا تاثيره
على ملف السلام في اليمن وايضا ما يخص
الدور السعودي في هذا الاتجاه بناحيه ملف
السلام والحراك السعودي باتجاه ح حله هذا
الملف وتفكيكه على الصعيد السياسي
والاقتصادي والانساني